all right people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message live
from the great state of texas that's
right guys i
am in dallas the free city
in the free state of texas uh i am here
at blaze studios
and i'm doing a bunch of shows with
glenn and the crew all day
a bunch of meetings a lot going on i'll
be here today
and tomorrow we got some special
surprises
on the way i'm feeling very good about
the the lighting right now god i've
never looked better it's amazing look at
that hair
um there is a lot happening in the world
right now
uh this gamestop situation and the robin
hood
traitors and the system striking back on
people
that's where i want to focus the the
first portion of the show today because
it's
actually crazy if you thought that our
institutions were crumbling if you
thought our cultural
and political institutions were having
problems well our financial institutions
are in a real humdinger of a mess right
now so we're going to talk about that
we're going to talk about a little more
incompetence coming out of our
new administration uh and that you're
not gonna believe this
uh but big tech may be coming for more
people than just the youtubers
and the mean tweeters they may be coming
for all the podcasters that's on the way
too
uh before i get to any of that though
guys i want to talk to you about
agar watches you know they sent me a
watch yesterday and i was going to bring
it i was going to wear the watch
on my wrist today i'm a lefty so i was
going to wear it on my right wrist today
but it arrived just as i was running out
of the house and i left it right there
but
they really make gorgeous watches uh the
ceo of aguard watches
has used the brand to take a absolutely
strong no bs stance against censorship
and the continued lockdowns with an
incredibly powerful video
that is called what is freedom which has
gone viral it's here on youtube
i watch it this morning it's actually
it's really great it's very much a
synopsis of everything that i've been
talking about
on this show their tbl watch is a
functional sturdy reliable piece
designed to honor
our law enforcement officials agar
watches stand proudly with
our law enforcement officers and are
proud to give 15 of all
profits from this piece to law
enforcement charities
watches are undeniably one of the most
notable ways to express yourself i wish
i was wearing the watch
perhaps the most historic of all
accessories actually all agar watches
are incredibly unique and well crafted
whether you're an avid watch where
or you're finally coming around to the
idea of adding a designer watch to your
wardrobe
there are several different styles and
movements that you can choose from visit
a guard watches that's with an e egard
watches.com use discount code ruben to
get 15
off your next timepiece that's
aguardwatches.com discount code reuben
and now back to me here in dallas okay
so i'm sure you guys
are all tracking uh this gamestop story
now before i get into the specifics of
the story and the
reaction from the white house which is
actually hilarious
well it's actually kind of depressing
it's depressingly hilarious or
hilariously depressing
uh i do want to note that as everyone's
talking about gamestop right now
you guys know that at one time i think
most of you know this i was a pretty
decent gamer okay
grew up playing the uh the nintendo
entertainment system 8-bit nintendo
entertainment system
i remember when my buddy john who's here
right now he was the first friend of
mine
when we were what like uh we're about
nine years old or so
to get nintendo and at one time i was so
good
at super mario brothers that using the
warp uh i could beat the entire game in
10 minutes and 30 seconds that was
something that i
was able to accomplish in about 1995 i
think sophomore year college wasn't
doing much studying back then
anyway i was assistant manager my first
job
out of uh college was assistant manager
at electronics boutique
which some of you who are a little older
may remember electronics boutique that
was the big video game store in
basically all the malls across america
i was an assistant manager there i moved
more pokemon red in 99 than anybody you
couldn't get one for game boy without
going through me okay especially if you
lived
on the eastern seaboard but
electronics boutique was eventually
acquired by gamestop so you see how i
made this story
sort of relevant to what's going on here
so i'm an integral part of this gamestop
story now before i tell you the
specifics of the story i thought it
would be funny
to show you the white house reaction to
the story first so even if you don't
know
exactly what's going on here i think
you'll understand why i want to show you
the white house reaction
to this gamestop short sell story first
this is white house press secretary jen
pasake
is the white house concerned about the
stock market activity we're seeing
around game stop
um and now with some other stocks as
well uh including
the the subsidiary or whatever the
company that was
uh blockbuster um and have there been
any conversations with the
sec about uh how to proceed
well um i'm also happy to repeat that we
have the first female treasury secretary
and a team that's surrounding her and
often questions about market we'll send
to them but our team is of course our
economic team including
secretary yellen and others are
monitoring the situation it's a good
reminder though that the stock market
isn't the only measure of the health of
our econo
our economy doesn't reflect how working
and middle class families are doing
as you all know from covering this we're
in the midst of a case shape recovery
america's workers are struggling to make
ends meet which is why the president has
introduced
this urgent package to get immediate
relief to families
all right so all right so the reason i
wanted to show you that clip before i
explain the story
to you is because guys we've got a woman
in charge of the treasury secretary
right she's the treasury secretary he's
a woman and she's got a team around her
so don't even worry about the story i'm
about to tell you about the the
hedge funds collapsing there's nothing
to worry about because a woman's in
charge so everything will be just fine
you understand that's the that's the
primacy of that this administration has
put on equity if a woman's in charge of
things it'll be okay if you got a gay
guy doing transportation don't worry the
roads aren't going to implode if you've
got a trans woman
in charge of health don't worry about
covet everything's going to be just fine
that's the ridiculousness that we're
putting up with
so if you don't know the story i'm going
to just read a quote from cnbc that'll
give you just a tiny bite of it because
i don't want to overload you with too
much here
this is from cnbc shares of gamestop
ballooned to more than 400 percent this
week and nearly 1
750 this year thanks to emboldened
retail investors in reddit chat rooms
trying to stick it to the wall street
pros the rookies are piling
into names heavily shorted by hedge
funds squeezing the stocks higher as the
institutions rush to cover their losses
shares of the am of amc entertainment
are up nearly 300
this week it goes on to talk about robin
hood which is the app that you can
download so you can get in the game
yourself and not do it through a big
brokerage house robinhood customers took
to twitter to express their outrage
surrounding the decision
robin hood has made a name for itself
through its mission to democratize
investing for everyone
the silicon valley startup with more
than 13 million users pioneered free
trading forcing the entire brokerage
industry
to drop commissions in late 2019.
okay so this is this is really
extraordinary stuff so without getting
into too much of the nitty-gritty of
short sales on stocks and i'll be
totally upfront with you this is not
totally my area of expertise okay so
we're gonna
as we talk about this over the coming
weeks i'll try to bring in some people
that are absolute experts in this stuff
but in essence
the the big brokerage houses were
shorting these stocks of gamestop of amc
of the company that formerly was
blockbuster video and a bunch of it in
an effort to then make more money as the
companies failed
a bunch of reddit people and robin hood
at people just regular old people like
you watching this and i bought some of
gamestop yesterday in the midst of all
this i bought a whopping 50
worth which i think is probably worth
about 58 bucks now a bunch of people
basically started
buying it because they just like the
idea of kind of screwing over the
brokerage houses
inflating the stock of something in this
case gamestop that really isn't worth
anything right malls are all closed it's
not like brick and mortar stores are
doing that well
so this is like an actual revolution by
the people
now what's more interesting about this
story is not just that the people
on their own are increasing the value of
a stock while
the hedge fund guys are trying to short
it and destroy it right that that's
interesting up in and of itself
but what's particularly interesting is
now the reaction
of the machine when i talk about the
machine you may call it the machine you
may call it the swamp whatever you want
to call it
this machinery that always sort of
exists
that that sort of keeps power where
power is well here's
a tweet from robin hood now remember
this is the app that was designed to
give the people back the power so that
they
could trade as they see fit the quote in
their tweet in light of current market
volatility
we are restricting transactions for
certain securities
to position closing only including amc
and gme so amc is the theater gme is
gamestop read more here okay so that's
super interesting the very people who
have given
us the power to trade on our own right
and and
caused something to allow you to make
financial decisions that are better for
you without
all the fees without going through major
brokerage things to just use your little
bits of money and and have some skin in
the game and get into the market and all
that stuff all of this really cool stuff
uh david has the app by the way and he
does a whole bunch of stuff on there uh
not major amounts of money but just has
fun like little trades and makes a
little bit here and whatever it is
and i'm sure you guys are doing it too
well now they obviously some pressure
was brought to bear
to the point that they issued a
statement that they just stopped
allowing sales
which is completely against their
mission statement as a company
so there's going to be obviously massive
lawsuits there's going to be crazy
investigations
so also all hell is sort of breaking
loose here so i was trying to find a
tweet or two from
from some experts who i actually respect
who could shed some light on onto the
situation
one is charles payne who's over at fox
business and he had
this to say the game stop phenomenon old
wall street and paid commentators
whined all day about gains game stop and
dissed retail investors
the same folks that dissed and missed
tesla if they are so
confident retail investors are so dumb
then
why these may then these mavens should
short these stockings
themselves sorry i need a little water
hang on a second here
so in essence what he's saying is let
the system work if if trading is
supposed to be free if the stock market
is supposed to be a place that anyone
can get in and anyone can
short a stock or inflate a stock or play
a game and be wise to how the world is
working
then every every rule you know should be
off right now everyone should be being
able to be part of the game but now
you've got the company
that democratized the thing in robin
hood actually stopping
people from trading it is absolutely
crazy so as i said i own some of this
gamestop stuff and i can't do anything
with it right now if i go into my app it
actually it says it's frozen or it's
they're just not trading or whatever it
is anyway this story is this is like the
story right now and i think this has
massive massive repercussions on
virtually every part of society
because as i said earlier you guys all
know about the institutional
collapses that we're having at the
educational level you get it at the
cultural level you get it at the
political level you get it
at the journalistic level that all of
the big things are collapsing and now
suddenly
it looks like the the mortgage houses
the brokerage houses
the big money people don't even
understand what the internet is doing
right if this is a bunch of people who
coordinate on reddit look reddit can be
a real freaking hellscape of evil people
but these are just people who are
coordinating to go in and put little
bits of money
to inflate the stock as the big guys
were shorting the stock and then
what happens is now the big guys are
gonna have to pay it back but it's worth
a lot more and they ain't gonna have any
money i think the the
the main uh the main trading house on
this thing
that was trying to short could be down
like like 1.5 billion dollars something
like that so this
this is just crazy and i think it's
going to bring together a lot of the
issues that we talk about here
in terms of economic populism and the
elites versus everybody else and that
most
of the issues of the day it is not left
verse right
it's not even conservative versus
liberal it's sort of the powers that be
versus everybody else and every single
time it seems that there's a populist
movement whether it was the tea party
movement
of ron paul a decade ago or it was the
trump
maga movement or now a movement of just
online people to to do what they want to
do with their own money
the machine seems to crush down on
people so i think we're just going to
see more and more of this and i think
the cascading effects
throughout the economy are going to be
wild but fear not people
we have a female treasury secretary a
woman's in charge
everything's going to be just fine give
them all your money
and all your power uh let's move on to
the second story speaking of uh we've
got this female
uh treasury secretary john kerry's back
right john kerry who you know he was a
marginal senator
never really did anything he did marry
into the heinz family so he's got the
big ketchup money
um but really never did anything he
failed his presidential bid he was a
pretty terrible secretary of state under
barack obama
there's that incredible video we played
it once but i'm sure many of you guys
have seen it already
of him talking about peace in the middle
east and that
you can't go to other countries first
you have to do everything through the
palestinians and it's like completely
the reverse
of everything that's happened in the
last couple years like this guy has been
wrong
on every major decision that he has made
period he's what has he accomplished
someone
tell me what he has accomplished well
his head keeps getting bigger so i don't
know he's injecting ketchup maybe i'm
not sure
but besides the size of his head
everything this guy's just sort of
accomplished nothing
well he now has he's now in charge of
our environmental policy because if you
can't really
do anything else it's like okay the
world's gonna end in 12 years according
to aoc let's get john kerry involved
uh here's john kerry from the white
house press briefing room
earlier this week they are seeing an end
to their livelihoods
uh what what do you say to them
particularly those people
who who president trump struck a chord
with on the campaign trail when he
promised to
save their jobs what is your message to
them right now and also to the oil
industry executives who are listening
are you putting them on notice today
well we didn't come here to put anybody
on notice except to the seriousness of
president biden's intent to do what
needs to be done to deal
with this crisis and it is a crisis
with respect to those workers no
no two people are more in this room are
more concerned about it than the
president of the united states
has expressed in every comment he has
made about
climate the need to
uh grow the new jobs that pay better
that are cleaner
is it just me or did he just tell all
those oil and gas workers to learn to
code
remember that from a year ago that was
going around twitter for a long time
that people
were telling much like this this robin
hood gamer
gamestop story um where people started
doing a movement and then the system
crushes down on it
remember there was this movement where a
lot of journalists were being told to
learn to code
and twitter actually stopped the trend
they didn't want people tweeting at
journalists to learn to code meaning get
a real job
so they stopped the trend and banned all
these accounts that sounds very very
similar
to what john kerry just said right there
which is yeah you guys have jobs but
there's a crisis
there's an environmental crisis and only
if we go into the fields that i'm sure i
have all sorts of financial connections
in and everyone i know has financial
connections in can we solve the crisis
and then you guys will learn to code
meaning you'll get
new jobs now i want to be very clear i
actually am
sympathetic to the idea that we could
start doing more with renewable
resources
the idea that there are new ways to
think about how we get power and what we
do
in in a time when the economy is
changing and the whole world is changing
and there are guys like elon musk that
are doing awful lot
to help those things along but the
dismissiveness
of just yeah you'll get a new job we'll
retrain you
of just the disdain that they have for
the average
working person is just extraordinary
and i checked while the while the video
was playing there john kerry is worth
250 million dollars
250 million dollars are any of you
watching this worth 250 million dollars
if you are we're looking for investors
and locals
but if not uh do you understand that
this this is what the elite class
who wants to live a certain way john
kerry has a private plane by the way
he's also telling you about carbon
missions
and you know environmental justice and
environmental equity that's a new one
we're hearing that all the time
um but yes you guys go learn to code go
get new jobs
but we here in the government we can
make an awful lot of money on all of
this stuff
and we can just recycle the same old
people who have never done good at
virtually
anything someone please in the comment
section can you please tell me something
good
that john kerry has ever done i just
don't know what it is
uh but speaking of incompetent people in
government there seems to be a theme to
the show today
uh we've got some video from c-span this
is
the new president joe biden and ah just
take a look
in the weeks ahead i'll be reaffirming
the federal government's commitment to
diversity equity and inclusion
and accessibility building on the work
we started
in the obama biden administration that's
why
i'm rescinded the previous
administration's harmful ban on
diversity and sensitivity training
and abolished the offensive counter
factual 1776 commission
unity and healing everything that old
man just said there was complete
nonsense first of all
yes trump did get critical race theory
we've talked about this many times on
the show obviously he did get it out of
the federal institutions
this diversity training was actually
injecting racism
into the system meaning that there are
no laws in the federal government that
stop
anyone from getting any sort of job
based on the color of their skin and by
the way if there were such laws i would
be railing against them
but there are no such laws right we all
know that there's no law
in the united states government that
says you as a black person can have a
job because of this or you as a white
person can have a job at this although
it's coming
because what he's saying now is we're
getting rid we're injecting
uh we're getting rid in essence of what
trump did
which was stopping this stuff from being
here so now we're injecting critical
race theory in
in which case they're going to want
equity right and what is equity
we're gonna have to have this many black
people and this many asian people and
this many white people and this many gay
people and this many women
and all these things thus discriminating
i know i say this whole time but call me
old school i would hire people
uh based on their skills their skills
and their competence that that's me when
i hire i have two companies now
when i hire i don't care what your skin
color is i don't care what your gender
is
or any of that stuff are you able to do
the job are you able to do the job
do you seem like a decent person do you
seem hard working and committed and you
want to grow together then you can have
the job
uh but we are about to inject all of
that stuff back into the system and then
by the way he talked about the 1776
project which the trump administration
had been working on for a couple months
and it was basically the idea
that we were going to put some
patriotism
some sense of something pro-america back
into our public schools
now that is not to say and and god knows
joe biden didn't read the entire
1776 project obviously i have not read
the entire thing myself however
i did sit in a meeting at the white
house about the 1776 project
and i can tell you that everything that
i heard in that meeting i did not speak
even in the meeting for for two hours
i just listened and they talked about uh
patriotism and telling an
honest uh history of the united states
not
denying slavery not doing talking about
anything
racist actually grappling with the
realities of our past
talking about how these were people of
their time and as i often talk about you
know a guy like thomas jefferson
who owns slaves while also writing the
laws that would free the slave an honest
assessment and acknowledgement of what
america is and putting that
into our public curriculum because so
much of it has been
just decimated by woke-ism right where
we're
we're taught our young people our
students our children are taught
that america is fundamentally evil that
the the first
driver of america was slavery i mean
it's absolute nonsense
but that they just dismiss they just
absolutely dismiss the 1776 project and
i i think if i'm not mistaken he called
it racist
he called it actually racist i mean
everything's racist i know it's racist
your lunch is racist your hat is racist
everything's racist paper's racist
racism it's everywhere
which i thought he got rid of racism
didn't he sign an executive order no
more racism the other day so it's like
man
i guess that thing didn't work um anyway
this is just
more sort of drivel from these people
and it's i think it's just
important uh to be aware of such things
and that's actually a perfect segue
to our final segment today because uh
one of the ways that you can stay aware
of these things is through youtube right
like these are not the things that
they're really talking about on cnn i
know you're not watching
cnn unless you're watching for laughs
but
in essence if you watch mainstream media
they're not going to really talk about
why you wouldn't want diversity and
inclusion
training in the government right they
would just tell you oh it's diversity
joe biden signed the thing to get rid of
trump's ban on diversity and inclusion
training and then you hear that and you
go wait a minute diversity is good
inclusion is good that must be good
that's what the average blue pill
person is thinking and if you just
consume mainstream media
in a weird way it's not your fault
you've been brainwashed for a long time
and they're gonna just continue mass
brainwashing you and they'll also tell
you oh don't worry that the economy is
crashing a woman's in charge of it
oh what happened your brother just drove
a car right off the road that
disappeared in the middle there was
supposed to be a bridge there was
nothing there don't worry a gay guy is
in charge of transportation
oh everybody you know has covet and
we're sending old people back into the
old age homes today don't worry the
assistant to the health secretary is
trans
that's what is being just just
absolutely pushed
on us right now and it is it is all
deeply connected
to what i started with about about
gamestop the just the
crumbling of the institutions okay we
get it you guys though if you're
watching this on youtube or you watch
blaze tv or you watch daily wire or
whatever it is however you get your
information outside of the mainstream
that is what is causing this this mass
awakening of america
not mass awokening of america which
because i think it's actually a very
small
but loud and and scary group of people
that keeps everybody woke i don't think
most people believe it i think it's a
bunch
of obvious nonsense that that actually
any 12 year old can really understand
that you want to be judged as you
not as you know the the color of your
skin or your
body parts um so those of you that watch
these shows
you guys are understanding that there's
something very different happening which
is why
you see what i did here it's why the
system now is coming
after all of us so it's not just that
they took out donald trump and they're
gonna
move on trump can't be on spotify right
it can't be on twitter it can't be on
spotify it's so stupid
um it's not just that they got him and
they're moving on well now they're
making and i've covered a couple of
these in the last few weeks
that you know trump supporters and
conservatives have to be deprogrammed
these are dangerous people they're not
just nazis anymore they're also domestic
terrorists
uh well msnbc did a
segment a day or two ago suggesting that
apple should extend
youtube's bannings and all of the
restrictions that they have
to podcasters to just independent
podcasters i've said enough
take a look social media's big crackdown
against false information
fringy conspiracy theories the kind that
many argue led to that deadly attack on
the capital a few weeks ago
but there is one mainstream platform but
that kind of
content is still up and reaching
millions of people
that's apple's podcast app take steve
bannon for example he is banned from
twitter he is banned from youtube
but you can still get his podcast
streamed through apple's app
that's where according to some new
extensive reporting from propublica
bannon says he gets millions of
listeners and is free to broadcast
things like election denialism
apocalyptic calls to action several
times a day
okay so i'm pretty sure msnbc just did a
full-on commercial for steve bannon's
podcast
which i haven't listened to but i'm
going to guess is probably better than
msnbc but putting that aside
for just a moment what they are now
saying to you is that you
person holding this little device that
we all have in our pockets that's
listening to us and stealing our souls
that it's not just that we're going to
ban certain thoughts
and ban certain people but also the
things that you listen to we are going
to systematically
look into each one and if they fall out
of the mainstream we're gonna get rid of
them so
i don't i truly don't know what steve
bannon is doing on his podcast but the
point is
we do still have free speech in america
and i get it this is not necessarily the
government
coming although when you have a giant
corporation like msnbc pushing giant
podcast
distribution networks to get rid of
things it starts coming kind of close to
government because of the
the ties between big tech and big
government but i'm going to go out on a
limb
and guess that steve bannon probably
wasn't
inciting violence directly or doing
something illegal but even if he was
then it would be the job of the united
states government to apply the laws
and arrest him or do whatever they must
do
the idea here is that of course what
they're going to say is
everyone again this is one of those
things it was like it was never going to
stop with alex jones it was never going
to stop with donald trump it's not going
to stop with steve bannon
and eventually they'll tell you that
glenn beck is too scary and eventually
they'll tell you that shapiro's too
scary and eventually they'll tell you
that i'm too scary and that what are you
gonna do at that point what are you
gonna do at that point so this is the
great challenge of our time i've never
been more focused on on solving this
thing i think a lot of people
are waking up really really fast as you
guys know
this is exactly why i created locals.com
finally i can tell you this we've run
this company now for two years it's been
growing really really nicely we're
getting our
our hockey stick growth right now a lot
of people flocking to locals
and finally in the last couple of weeks
because of all the craziness silicon
valley people that wouldn't take my
calls when i was trying to reach out to
them before
suddenly they're reaching out to us and
we're having a lot of discussions with
people because there's a chance now
there's a chance to fix some of this
stuff check out what we're building at
reubenreport.locals.com and that's of
course where you can communicate
directly with me
by the way if you want more insight into
all of the craziness of how
the financial world works how stocks
work short sales all this stuff
i interviewed jordan belfort two days
ago so it was right before the the
gamestop stuff was happening jordan
belfort is the
is the original wolf of wall street he
is the guy
that wrote the book based on his own
life that leo dicaprio
filmed that incredible incredible movie
i think it's one of the best movies the
last 20 years probably
so i have jordan belfort part one is on
youtube right now and uh the full
episode is at reubenreport.locals.com
totally ad free
and tomorrow guys i will be back right
here in dallas in a different studio
they've got incredible i mean these guys
really have
just incredible studios here in in
dallas maybe i'll give you guys a tour
a little later uh but we'll be doing a
live panel with
three of the blaze hosts who i won't
mention right now just to give you a
little bit of a surprise that of course
will be at 11 a.m
pacific 2 p.m eastern and
all right i got a million things to do
oh and i think we're going to do a live
meet and greet in dallas tonight
for reuben report members only so i will
be posting our secret meeting place
a little bit later on the locals
community for subscribers only so if you
want to have a drink with me and you're
in the dallas-fort worth area
reubenreport.locals.com all right
everybody have a great day